808 mort l'a reçue renevey son triste
record de mortalité depuis août les
chiffres étaient aux alentours de 790
décès quotidiens les virologues russe
explique ce pic de décès par la
propagation du variante delta le non
respect des gestes-barrières ainsi que
le faible nombre des personnes vaccinées
la russie en compte seulement 39
millions sur 146 millions écouter
personne ne porte de masque personnes ne
respectent les distances ni les mesures
de protection ne se désinfecter les
mains rien il s'agit d'une violation de
toutes les règles sanitaires et
épidémiologiques
énormément de gens ne sont pas vaccinés
un nouveau variant est apparu il se
propage rapidement plus vite dans les
contacts ce sont des choses indépendante
pour se protéger soi même et ses proches
il faut se faire vacciner si les gens ne
se font pas vacciner ne respectent pas
les mesures de confinement de quoi
parle-t-on quand auto décontamination
des hospitalisations tous les deux sont
en baisse ces tendances peut être
observé non seulement à moscou mais
aussi dans d'autres régions russes
écoutez nous constatons une diminution
du nombre de nouveaux cas d'infection
une diminution du nombre de patients
hospitalisés dans différentes régions
la baisse du taux est à peu près la même
c'est peut-être simplement étiré dans le
temps le système de santé acquis de
l'expérience au cours de ces 18 mois
cela nous permet de dire que nous
n'avons pas peur que nous n'avons aucune
crainte face un scénario négatif qui
pourraient potentiellement se dérouler
en septembre près de vingt deux mille
nouveaux cas de couronner virus ont été
détectés en russie ces dernières 24
heures dont près de 2300 à moscou depuis
le début de la pandémie 6,5 millions de
russes ont contacté le coc vide le
nombre de décès s'élève désormais à plus
de 168 milles personnes